hello everybody good afternoon and
welcome back from lunch it was wonderful
to see so many engaging interactions
going on around the poster sessions and
I hope you enjoyed the posters so it's
my honor to introduce Weiwei Joe so
where we Joe received his PhD in Beijing
Union Medical College and after
postdoctoral training at Washington
University in st. Louis at the NIH and
working on as a research scientist here
at the McGovern Institute for brain
research
he joined Siot as a principal
investigator in 2014 and his talk title
this afternoon is research insights from
the brain cognition and brain disease
Institute at science first I'd like to
thank the organizer who gave us this
opportunity to introduce our Institute
the brain cognition and the brain
disease instead of itis it it is with
greater pressure and honor for us
actually original this talk actually
over directed Living Well should come to
present this but he cannot make it a
trip because he cannot look at with the
path so anyway just as sabe mentioned I
have been working here for long long
time for quite a long time so it's very
nice to be back and to be too many
friends in this bigger McGovern history
of the family so a brief history about
our youth videoed the pictures over in
steeled and our Institute is established
official on November 16 2014 and we are
very grateful grateful to Macaroni
studios and the foundation the
collaboration with us and the macaronis
period is very helpful for us to growing
up later at the two side as I said under
my car Mysterio the sign
for collaboration in the past eight
years above European have awaited as
many many times gave us a lot of
suggestion and we also have ongoing a
research project a date I will mention
about the transgenic model parameter
model in the past four years over in
still higher grow very quickly 2015 we
have this totally the number research
about 45 the current we have a total
research almost one 200 now we have a
city investigator and certain associated
investigator here is the organization of
our Institute we have the academic
advisory board our leadership included
the director professor leaping one me
and the three assistant investigator
based on the research direction we have
for reform for Research Center the
Center for the neuro circle and behavior
the center of Opera and the intelligence
technology and the Center for neural
development and annuity qianqiu disease
and the center of fortune editing and
parenthesis models based on what the
policy about how to form the studio I
would say that this to instill this two
centuries more on the system and the PCB
levels is to a molecular and cellular
level the Center for the neural circuit
and Blimpie and the behaviors lead by
Professor leaking wall and this is the
last century in our experience almost
half the size of our in-studio
this century is for sound neural circuit
of an innate behavior and the circuit
dysfunction in reality the brain
disorder they also first the mechanism
underlying can Lear modulation of neural
circuits function they also divide some
technique and a tour for occurred
research
not I will show some example of research
in this Center the first is about your
circle of the innate behavior
leapin was guru bhai will investigate
the new circular underlies innate
behavior they identify subaru clickers
RP Salam's neural circuit response for
innate behavior they also started in a
defensive response to have investigated
the neuro circle the beaten super
clickers and our state that immediately
distress induce until saga salary
defensive response Liberman's group also
study on the orbit of epigenetic
exhibition of a silly related activity
they have done the optical see
activation of a hyper camber carbon
logic in the neural Federal Reserve in a
long-lasting inhibitory effect on the
theater in removing animal post but we
can see at the table is without the
optical circulation after the optical
sedimentation we consider city-related
actually have been reduced significantly
they also derive some tall for the
neural modulation and the recording they
provided the MIDI channel the
multi-channel
optical array for the circle dissection
we will
they also devised a soft stretchable
optical fiber for chronic optical
circulation the center of Oprah and the
intelligent technology me lead by me our
central have a four member and - you
must be kidding me and Achaia and
another associate investigator also have
been focused on the neural mechanism we
show cognition such as we show attention
visual categorization and the social
behaviors we also recently we also carry
out some research neural network model
photos
mechanism we also studied the mechanism
machinery colonization of cognitive
impairment in summary disorder as we
know I have been working in pubs lab so
my research has been focused and neural
mechanism visual attention in the past
year without us Takeda neural circuit
between prefrontal cortex and visual
coders underlying the future attention
we also study the neural circuit
potential quarter and premiere
underlying spatial attention China in
over a century
you must peek at the new neural
mechanism social behaviors we have
studied the social defeat and the from
dissect prefrontal phe circuit that
immediate is social of defensive
behavior also what with people in
civilian university and study the social
dominance and figure out the prefrontal
and the preferred dosto media prefrontal
color and immediate also salamis this
circuit is an important role in this
ominous behemoth the Center for neural
development and neural deterrent disease
is lead by Professor Cheney and his
central have us remember associate
investigator they are interesting in the
mechanism of our markers of a neuro
developmental and a neurodegenerative
disease they also are interested in
contribution of a peripheral immerse it
into the neural degenerative disease
this is the study from from Chinese
Chinese work they attended they have a
working on the identification of genetic
risk factor of 8000 us and big data
analysis and other my sir I don't know
and they identified
Warren and the PNG 15 in the Chinese
population that the country build the
Alzheimer's disease risk and galia in
the essential university gave the
peripheral immune system and the neural
energy of disease and they found out the
peripheral in from in fro treating email
email sales contributed or Parkinson
disease progression
the fourth central for the gene gene
editing brain disease model is lead by
professor Zhang hua do jihad in this
central have a silent limits together
and the associated masticator in this
century have focused and to divide by
non-human primate and Jordan a disease
model usually editing mastered
they also explore the mechanism of
operating disorder in this disease
models he has work by collaboration
between this century above and go team
is about the sixth region editing monkey
model
evidence in this model this shows a
mutation in social social part I think
copying they saw that detail and I just
mention a little bit and also the doctor
true unity in this venture he
investigated silence processing in the
purity and associational learning we
find out the cell in this area a baleen
the cell you see of a city mullah and
they also find this info silences the
one group of themself where the mouse
cannot learn associative tasks so it
means the purity can taking the
associative learning by providing
dynamic representation of Sakuma lies
silencing
now here is a very brief introduction of
our Institute if you have a further
question about the power and other
culture I'll be very happy to address
and this last slide about the changing
and Hong Kong spirit of brain science
actually recently the shinigami approved
to establish the since period we should
have a positive influence over in spirit
a little bit background from this map
you can see hong kong here ginger here
they are located in this so-called
Guangdong Hong Kong and Macau Bay Area
market orange and recently the Chinese
government announced the Guangdong Hong
Kong Macau greater Bay Area initiative
to promote the further development in
this area which also included the
promoted at the ones of a science and
technology in this area so in this
background Shenzhen decided to establish
this unchanging Hong Kong experiences
and this is a new instead of the found
in the bar changes where we build joined
by said Hong Kong University of Science
and Technology and other research
institution in the two cities this is
still plan to have like 60 FPS with a
recurring fundamental and applied
research on your science last I'd like
to thank the funding agency as I'd say
Ministry of Science and Technology China
Chinese the concerns going to province
and the Union City finally we are ready
to lead for to my governance period and
my common foundation for their help and
support okay
[Applause]
questions for Weiwei
hello it's very admirable that these
large consortia are being formed in
China across different geographic areas
it's really wonderful and my question is
is there any formal cooperative
organization among these various large
conglomerates it's extremely impressive
I mentioned the Chinese per impala and I
think this the video the establishing
different cities like our changes like
changing Shanghai and the Beijing mainly
cooperated to this will be the parabola
and also we have a connection with the
Shanghai and Beijing
thank you it's fantastic
you are research institute here
similarly a lot of work had been done in
the basic research and NIDA kind
Kinetico that catalysis had been done
for instance
Oh Simon disease and Parkinson's
in a clinical patient so the applied
research is very important in the future
of our Institute and we are they
establish a collaboration with hospital
in the local area and the guangzhou a
single well yeah because our you still
still young by the way were further
divided in that part have a further
collaboration with the hospital to Cairo
this if there are no further questions
please join me in thanking dr. Jo
[Applause]